can you guys hear me
let me just bring this over here
boom
all right you guys should be able to
hear me fine boom
let me mute this other stream
what's going on guys as you can see
we're going to be doing this little Live
Chat thing here we still got about
another 13 14 minutes before we get down
with this before we become the the
biggest Menace to Society in Hogwarts
Legacy I'm gonna go through there now
I'm gonna I'm gonna cost so much chaos
guys you have no idea now now let's
let's have some laws let's have some
rules let's put some Foundation down all
right
I'm not gonna open up being the
Voldemort of Legacy all right I know I'm
not strong enough to take on teachers I
know
and I ain't doing that
first thing I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
build up some some spells I'm gonna
build up some some attack patterns
and then
I'm gonna go in
on everything
you know because I honestly feel like
and I truly with everything in me
felt like these teachers gonna wreck me
if I go in there and just start casting
spells on them
I appreciate it man I appreciate it
appreciate it thanks for watching yeah
go on there and share this on Twitter
man tell everyone I'm here man tell
everyone I'm here
what else you started with can you
choose a house to start with like how
does that work
how does it work can someone explain to
me how it works
uh
foreign
I think you can choose any of the four
is it good for or is it bad for
I don't know a whole lot about the
houses I don't know what they stand for
so you guys are gonna have to show me
you got to you're gonna have to breathe
the information into me I don't know
I trust you guys though
not really I don't trust you guys 100
but I trust you to a point
you know I know you guys like trolling I
know you do
oh I'm I'm excited man I I went with
enlighten me
yeah give me one second guys
all right I'm back
foreign
guys hold up hold up
you
just a different app
how to do it for the culture guys how to
do it for the culture
you got to go with Jedi School
is that really a Jedi School in this
game don't be playing with me
you guys know I don't take jokes very
well
never been an HP fan but Raven what's HP
Hubble Puff
I I think the little app said that that
to be Hubble puff or
whatever it is
I don't know guys I don't know
appreciate the The Shield man appreciate
the [__] we about to get this going
you know I got my little Crow my little
core controller
[Music]
I got my
Advanced GG
and you got you guys want to stay up for
a little bit and do a little bit healthy
you can use that
oh my God okay
let's move this over here
all right all right you know I'm taking
this all
right it's just too uncomfortable right
now
too uncomfortable
oh it's taken forever man
eight minutes
I mean I guess I could switch to um
to the cheese already but I mean at this
point miles away
I'm looking at some stuff guys want to
see the library of games I have hold up
foreign
make got a little bit bigger
ah let's just put me right here
I feel comfortable right here
so as you guys can see I got my games
got my game selection got us some
Destiny 2 some Hogwarts Legacy let me
turn that off let me put do not disturb
foreign
some midnight Suns some fortnite some
Persona 5 Royal got some Divinity
original sin is there any Early Access
period or something for the game yeah
you can get three days if you bought the
hundred dollar version or whatever it is
I I we we got the 100 version because we
want to make sure that we cover the game
and you know the the closer we get into
what's into you know mid-February
because I'm expecting hopefully
something with atomic heart so I'm gonna
try that game out I don't know Atomic
car don't look very appealing to me but
I'm willing to give it a try if you guys
want me to
all right there we go
we about to we about to get into this
man
I don't know who I'm gonna be yet though
I don't think I should be Slytherin I
want to be I want to be a menace by
surprise I feel like if I pick Slytherin
they're gonna be looking at me
everywhere I go They're gonna be looking
at me and I don't want to do that I want
it to be a surprise when I start to go
crazy I want them to generally be
confused
I want them to be confused
Slytherin game look man Lucius Augustus
I want to go into Slytherin I do but
part of me feels that if I want to be
real about this
and be a menace to society when it comes
to the Hogwarts Legacy
I gotta I gotta pick so you know I would
probably have to pick like Gryffindor
the people that Harry Potter was
you know because I feel like they
wouldn't ex they wouldn't expect me to
be evil
they they would they wouldn't expect it
we about to see though we about to see
we're about to see what goes down
choose Hufflepuff and become evil it's
helpful supposed to be like the good
people like the good people of it
it's like an evil Hedgehog
okay
is there any forms of rewards for
choosing one class over the other
is there
do I get an award if I choose one class
over the other
I'm curious if I get a reward for it
I appreciate Diggity
Diggity I think I think that's how I
pronounce it Diggity
we got wal Diggity
all right let me look here
we we doing this man we doing this we
close and I told you I told you that the
the goal is to be a menace I want to to
them not even think once it catches up
to the Harry Potter I want them to not
even think about Voldemort like I said
in the podcast you couldn't speak
Voldemort's name I want me to be erased
from the history books
that's what I want
you know I I want to be such a menace
that they're scared to even say my name
where's attic this is attic man you know
I even got the anime shirt got the my
hero shirt you know there's there's Duca
that's in fortnite
guys put go on Twitter and say I'm live
man
share the link
do me a solid
go on Twitter
and share the link and say addict is
live and he's going to be a menace to
society
now it's attic with a t add equal for C
is the beer to do
we are going
to
across so many things you know I got
someone in there said for me to pick
Hufflepuff Hufflepuff are very good
people very loyal to their friends but
outside of that hufflepuss are known to
be the most missile screw see I want it
I want it to be a surprise like when I
decide that I've had enough
I want them to be like yo he just went
crazy I didn't just killed 15 students
and two teachers but I told you we ain't
attacking anyone until I feel confident
because they said you can hit anyone it
seems like I don't know if it's at the
beginning but there you can do whatever
you want in this game it turned to being
good or evil we cannot risk getting
capped by a teacher
I'm scared of the teachers they terrify
me we are not getting capped by a
teacher
will learn their spells and then we'll
cap them
but see if I pick Slither and they're
going to suspect it
Brandon we don't want them to suspect it
we want to be one of those things where
it's like you know it's a TV show where
you're like oh my God it just happened I
want them to think of that when they see
me
uh zero pile they're going to like a uh
New Zealand uh I could have done that
but I was spending the day with a girl
so I was like you know I'm already going
to come here and stream this so why
why come here when I'm already going to
stream it so I got to spend the day with
her come here and now I'm playing this
but anyway back to the plot twist
we are going
to cause so much Havoc
you know I don't know if we're gonna
cast Dark Art spells I don't know what
we're gonna do
Ravenclaw
bam here we go here we go let's go to
the live scene
we
are in this for the Long Haul
hide
and then you read it
off no we turn in that menu reader you
ain't gonna keep reading me a bedtime
story I can read my own bedtime story
yeah let's turn that off
like the accessibility though they give
you plenty of things people that's blind
people that can't see that very well I
like I like when they give you these
options
can I turn motion blur off because it
looks like it's out of control
it's cool it's cool we'll figure it out
later
obviously we're going for performance
chat we we ain't doing the the frame per
second we're going for performance
foreign
what's the worst thing that can happen
we go
we good for right now
Dark Art pass this is what I'm talking
about [__] How You Gonna Be a Menace if
you don't have dark art chat
dark arts is where you turned
we're claiming this reward online we got
a an onyx hippopot Griff Mount you may
soar the Scottish islands of the back of
this girl from black I don't know we
ain't trying to butcher that but we got
it look see there there it's like
they're speaking to me they want me to
be a villain they're giving me Dark Art
set and they're giving me a black
griffin I feel like
I feel like that's that's the sign of
the gaming God saying screw stuff up
Dark Art Garrison hat
yeah I'm about to be such a menace to
this game
uh we good here
they know they know what I'm about to do
we are pleased to inform you that you
have been accepted to the Hogwarts
School of Witchcraft and wisdom Drive is
a fifth year student so what happened to
the first four
do they just say yo go in this advanced
class we know you're not a wizard but
you're a wizard today
you had to learn something before why
would they put you as a fifth year
student
look
we got the advanced GG go pick up your
Advanced EG with code iron Lords
you know get get that
see I ain't saying a Coke well you know
I ain't saying no drug reference so some
joking joke reference that you know the
uh that everyone else be doing you know
if you want something to keep you up a
little bit
go to advantages and use code iron Lords
all right so who we gonna be who we
gonna be oh the game looks good
oh
they got some pre sent
who should I who should I be chat tell
me which one
get that powder
look at this dude
[Music]
man look at him look at him this dude
this dude looks like he's gonna try to
sell me drugs in the future
the Dude Looks like he's going to try to
get me to buy an eight ball or something
Go With It Harry
uh we'll be the drug dealer that's fine
I don't care
this stuff's never really mattered to me
I know like character customization
matters to a lot of people but it's
never really mattered to me to be honest
with you
look at them fat
cheeks
man I'm gonna be a ginger that song will
be
do you prefer playing as a male or
female when the choice is given to you I
don't think I've ever been a a woman in
any kind any kind of game to be honest
with you
[Music]
oh I can have glasses
I like these glasses
let's see what this is hairstyles all
right
[Music]
I want to look crazy
yeah this is it
this is it right here
[Music]
hold up
what kind of colors can I make it
yeah let's be green green hair man let's
do this
oh you can get some gnarly scars
hold up we got the Harry Potter scar
let's get this one I like this one
look like I've been through some stuff
man
a few cobweb I'm eager to get dog it was
wonderful I believe I'm really going to
enjoy this class
I am indeed a student but I could very
well be able to help you
that was quite something
we are
Lord
addict
we are wizard
[Music]
they won't let me be myself
your name has entered contained
restricted words
attic with a C
yeah they would let me use addicts hey
but I use the attic with a C
ah it appears we are almost game looks
good guys game looks good
see we didn't have a bit more time to
spend on spell casting I presume you've
been practicing the Spells we worked I
have Professor it looks like the the one
that is
you'll be a force to be reckoned with
when you come out uh the the rat in one
of the I think president of basketball
thank you
[Music]
I've operated to more vaguely Define
destinations than this though I confess
I may have miscalculated slightly on my
first try and gave quite the Fright to
some theater goers in the West End
it's been much too long when I received
your owl I must say I best not speak
here Elias are
of course why don't we speak you guys
don't know this but you're actually
seeing the origin stories of available
ceremony to get to wonderful ideas the
origin stories of a villain doesn't mind
me tagging along not at all sir after
you
ages since I'd been to the castle
would be good to see the old pile of
rocks
[Music]
I like the way this dude's looking
he's up to no good
[Music]
Warner Brother games
foreign
[Music]
Microsoft rumor to be buying these
people
[Music]
oh
there's a different Avalanche there's
two Avalanche video game studios
just barely
and who is your traveling companion
a new student
new
yes sir I'm starting school as a fifth
year
how extraordinary it is indeed none of
the faculty has ever heard of anyone
being admitted to Hogwarts so late nor
have I of course as the others that's
because that's how the villains always
starts he's always gifted and then it
turns out he's gonna be way worse of a
villain ever man well you couldn't have
asked I want my own steak though
is not only an exceptional teacher he's
also remarkably intuitive and gifted
wizard
Mr ozric is prone to flattery I dare say
it's one of the reasons he's risen so
far at the ministry
have you seen this
I have opinions differ as to how great a
threat Round Rock really is
although I've yet to convince my
colleagues that the ministry I believe
he is a significant how quick do you
guys think I should become a villain it
was your wife first hour of the game
first two hours of the game this
activity it's months ago Miriam how
she I want to know and rock before she
does the chat feels about me becoming a
villain industry knew about his
activities ASAP
before I could respond am I a forgiving
villain receive this
am I a forgiving film that's the
question do I forgive
it came to me via her owl
but with no correspondence
I can only assume that she had to get
rid of it quickly
to keep it safe presumably from ran Rock
I cannot open it whatever magic protects
this is powerful indeed it looks like
Goblin metal
that glow
I don't see a blow
remember guys
Advanced GG cold iron Lords
Marvin's beard how did you eat
we did
yo yeah
[Music]
I bet you that was the most delicious
food that dragons had in a minute
what's a waiver and isn't it because it
doesn't have feet
[Music]
that's totally my my dragon that's my
future mouth
the key
[Music]
[Applause]
are you all right
you're hurt
perhaps a bit
take this it's wig and World potion
stuff will write you in a second
I assume this is the tutorial
let's heal myself
what happened
poor George
I can't believe you
oh that's cool what the hell got into
that damn thing attacking a carriage
mid-air
a typical Dragon would never
sir
where are we how's my camera look chat
how's it look but that key you
discovered was clearly important
did I look fine
I'm feeling better sir if you'd like to
look around a bit
I would
stay close we've no idea who created
this Porky
or why
look man COG if Microsoft would have
stole this it could have been there just
one
someone go on Twitter
tag Cog and say hog Works Legacy could
have been that just one yo this looks
nice this looks really nice
this has not been the day either of us
expected but Miriam sent that Porky to
George for a reason
and I believe that she hey I feel like
this would be a new IP in pursuit of
whatever it was meant to lead to
if you're sure you're
all wrong me I'd like to have a look
around absolutely sir good
let's see if we can find a path
I can't get over how good this game
looks
mind your step
okay I just cover plan just swing on him
come here a good question
Miriam I'm here
imagine looking behind you and you just
see someone running like this yes
powerful magic wielded by a rare few
I'm playing on Xbox time
Xbox series X
that self a stronghold of that ancient
Magic
I don't know where she came into
possession of the port key
but I am certain it was to do with that
search Ah that's the part down there I
choose performance Z you know I choose
performance we don't do that Fidelity
stuff around here we don't care about
textures if it looks good enough it
looks good enough you know what we care
about not playing a PowerPoint
that's what we care about disappeared
from The Wizarding World
look what it could do but magic is no
different than any power
what really matters is though it
probably does look better on PC most
likely
is that ice it's not cold enough here
it appears to be a sort of enchantment
someone wanted to block this path
let's see some of that one work you were
practicing
focus on the center
focus on you
How You Like Me Now
you're gonna be the one that I tell all
my evil plans to
you're going to be the one that I tell
everybody to to not say my name
excellent
use your camera just like
some players prefer to select targets
and move the Avatar with the same Thumbs
Up by disabling
oh
look at that man
thank you sir
I'm okay with it though I'm okay with
playing on uh on console
it looks really nice on console
we're close now uh so far it's looking
like a mixture of everything but I've
really been in battle to really justify
what it is yet
let's get to that then we'll figure out
how exactly they want you to use it
once I fired a couple people
because I I assume I'm not going to
Massacre people for a while like I said
I'm scared of the teachers
the teachers is the biggest
oh no because clearly I'm a five-star
student you know I'm gonna go kill the
first class first
because you know we don't want them
growing up we don't want
students with a Vengeance to come at me
in the future because I massacred all
they friends
we got to make sure we take them all out
we can't have a movie being made on a
student coming after us in the future
I don't know why this is satisfying this
here I suspect they valued their privacy
that Porky led us here for a reason
let's have a look around for anything
that seems
out of place
you mean this big giant wall here
[Music]
so it looks like you you hold in um the
right analog stick to to Mark and you
press left and right on the right angle
on six and switch
it's a mural of some kind
perhaps our host was a noted seer
interesting
I will be streaming this tomorrow on the
on the
my twitch Channel
okay
what's going on
they want me to search things
who's home
whose home was this
foreign
if you want to see
Migo bizoku
on people tomorrow
because I'm sure tomorrow's when it's
really going to get bad tomorrow's when
I'm really gonna go crazy there there is
my Twitch account I'm gonna start
streaming more I really enjoy streaming
ugh
dude didn't tell me who that was
can I climb up there in somewhere
the only biggest thing I think I'm not I
don't know if I'm gonna like or not is
I'm not I'm never really generally a fan
of no melee combat
I'm not saying there's no melee combat
in this game but I generally gravitate
towards maybe I promise it's starting
again
thought well could it be blocking
Professor fake
how odd
why would someone have conjured that
Enchanted Stone here
and how is there a room behind it
room
I don't see anything
there's that glow again like the glow on
the porky container
we going in here
what in Merlin's name
Patrick's heart
where are we
I don't believe it
hello
what's going on
Goblin Bank
[Music]
this game looks really good guys like
like aesthetically it looks really good
just a moment
oh
[Music]
welcome to gringott's Wizarding Bank
vote number 12 I presume
you the key
the White's Pokey oh yes of course I
wonder what's in this
this way then
it's a very visually impressive
oppressive game I will say that
after you
I wouldn't be listening to No Goblin
look how easy he just got up on that
you guys couldn't pay me it was inside
the cards if you don't wish to lose them
foreign
I'm kind of curious why they're not
showing up on the actual IOP chat I have
to figure out why that's not happening
[Music]
it's a security measure experience the
thief down fall before have you heard
please
number 12 was commissioned shortly after
Gringotts was founded over four
centuries ago in
pops up
at the settling with quite a distance to
go
Vault number
vote 12.
momentous day
on your way these goblins give me the
chills man
foreign
was glowing
like the clue you saw on the bulky
container that darker I saw that same
glow in the dragon's collar yeah what
was that we were just wondering about
that goblet back there did he watches
over the oldest section of the bank
rare anyone goes there anymore
I remember this was in like Chamber of
Secrets or something like that these
type of banks
the character designs okay do it it's a
very impressive looking game it really
is
[Music]
when was the last time this Vault was
accessed a goblin has been stationed at
my desk for hundreds of years
in that time no one has visited Vault
12. until today
bones 12. thank you for your help
all right all right let's let's let's go
in here I'd shut it
if I was there might shut it on my way
and then close the door okay he gonna
close the door
how do you get out
let me think
that must be something here hmm
Reveal Your brands
revelio you guys think this might be a
game of the year
one it's interesting some little
mini games
there I saw something
move a bit closer and try again
appreciate one Average Joe I'm gonna try
to do a little bit more twitch man I
really try
that's a stop
I do Professor that symbol has the same
glow as the one I saw on the pool yeah I
feel you I feel you know I mean when it
comes to stuff like that it's just a
weird territory it's gonna be hard to
separate people's emotions with you know
the game itself and I get it I do
you know I get it she says some stuff
she shouldn't have said but at the same
time a lot of people made this game and
you know it's sad that their work is
being overlooked just because of one
individual's opinion yeah
[Music]
oh I see some sort of some sort of test
I do
but to what and I can't say
close there will be no disapparating if
things go poorly not out of green Gods
oh this looks so good guys it looks like
that place in um Lord of the Rings the
mines
hey uh aesthetic appreciate you coming
by man
I see something up ahead what is it yeah
one Average Joe uh I'm gonna restart to
stream on the floor
what I normally do
um one Average Joe's I stream when we
cover a new game on IOP I'll stream the
first time on the IOP Channel and
usually I don't play it anymore after
that uh but I'm gonna start streaming
the rest of the playthroughs on the TWiT
on my twitch channel uh so definitely go
there like I said chat it's in the it's
in the chat right there I'll put it in
there again uh you know follow me on
Twitch I know I know a lot of the
YouTube people don't want to mess with
twitch and I get that I get it
foreign
it suddenly seemed as if the ground was
swirling about
are you all right
yes sir I'm fine
what's going on you seem to have caused
the floor to change
statue
what statue
I see some sort of statue but only is a
reflection in the floor
[Music]
Rebellion I presume this is what you saw
reflected in the floor
it is the reflection's still there this
is interesting the statue's positions
don't match olive oil on Twitch if we
get a hot tub stream the direction of
the light explain the fact that you want
to see me all wet in the tub says a lot
about yourself this is a lot about you
it's okay it's okay
oh now we do an ASMR as well as a hot
tub string
see I don't have a hard time I don't
even have a hot tub man I don't even
know how I would even get one
you've acquired the one light neutron
lumius has all kind of been spotted into
your spell slot lumius creates a light
at the tip of your wall to help you see
in dark areas
lumos well done
now the reflection is turning towards me
does follow the light
okay come on man
so I'm curious in the chat you know I
always ask this uh we're very curious
and stuff like this where did you guys
come across this from
you know it's easier for us to figure
out stuff we know more information I
need I'd like to know where you guys
found us from
yo this dude's a beast
this is what I said I can't mess with
teachers
ah
y'all like this dude
yeah get out of here
I'm the future Minister Society
nah we good we good we don't need help
I'm a menace to society
we look really bad
yeah what you gonna do
what you gonna do
a villain can't have a bad origin story
someone shut my door please
no no turn on my light turn on my light
thank you
I'm here man
I appreciate it Julio ACG family man
he's a good dude
Professor where are you
this isn't good
lumos
yeah that's a big theme for caulk I
assuming you came from the last word
I think I'm going to stream a lot of
Destiny see I want my streams to be like
you know just uh Good Vibes that's
talking that's why I want my streams I
don't want it to be about you know me
playing certain games I don't want to
like put myself in a box Ah that's where
they're leading me glow again
lumos
come on man
oh hold up
suppose I'm on my own this time
yeah it's kind of scary to be on our on
our own
the combo gets technical
[Music]
what to be honest with you
um flame I have to be a uh
with their reflections
I have to be a uh a variety streamer
because that is the only way because I
review games I can't just play one game
I see you
you level what you doing
one day I'm Gonna Be a Menace
I'm gonna be the the everyone's gonna
know me they're gonna they're gonna fear
me
a good origin story
has got to be strong man nobody's scared
of a punk
I gotta be feared
foreign
I know you ain't gone
I see you
Lord addict is invincible
Voldemort don't know what happened to
him and besides that I was I was
tripping there man yeah but I see you
I see you over to my left
there's a dude behind me too I see him
too
yeah see
call me Lord addicts
we don't play as in these streets
what you doing
did I give you permission to move
oh God there's so many of them
but villains know how to do this man
one day I'm gonna be feared by everybody
and no one fears a loser
revealed
Rebellion
this is how I become Unstoppable
foreign
okay okay
that's good they make you do it so you
actually know how to do it they don't
just show you and then say yo I hope you
learn
I feel you but not everything got to be
a Co-op multiplayer kind of thing
here maybe give us a mode where we could
play like
like Quinta uh whatever the broom
game is maybe let us play something like
that with your friends
or do like
like where you fight each other and like
an arena or something you could do
something like that maybe two on twos or
something like that but I can if they
want to give us the ability to play the
whole single player I don't I can't I
gotta respect it
so far so good
is this is this
a chat
this looks like some dark magic stuff
chat
hold up hold up
this looks like some dark magic stuff
and you know what has a dark magic
villains
whatever I you're not gonna mispronounce
it man I'm not that good at pronouncing
stuff
[Music]
foreign
there you are
how did you
what is this place I don't know
but I found this floating above that
basin
that is no mere basin
that is offensive
for viewing memories
I wonder
foreign
let's just pour it all in there
Follow My Lead
[Music]
who is this
the kind of powers I want
all is in place
the porky is well hidden perhaps too
well
I wonder if the path we've created may
be impossible to follow
it will only be impossible for one who
cannot see traces of ancient magic as I
can your ability to see what others
cannot will not be enough possible
we are entrusting the one who embarks I
know ain't nobody's selling this man
Nicholas Cage could never get in this
Vault anything to obtain
and the responsibility that accompanies
it
responsibility they've done all that we
can they assume I would go the right way
they assume wrong
I'm gonna use all this power to take
over all of Hogwarts
and the most cruel and unusual ways
possible the glow that surrounded them
yes sir
astonishing can I see Magic
traces of an ancient magic to be precise
the magic that Miriam had always
believed existed
could never
[Music]
Miriam and perhaps George
died in Pursuit we got some really good
stuff for you man a lot of stuff's been
happening for us here lately and you it
seems
are the key to understanding why we got
some good stuff for you we're in the
process of setting up an interview right
now someone's coming I hope you guys
enjoy it man me and me and the in the
Lords we've we've went through a lot
of stuff to
to really give you guys good coverage it
was right
Goblin
seems my reputation precedes me we ain't
worried about this guy getting to think
no one was ever going to visit this is
gonna be my future Huntsman in the
future in the future man he gonna help
me commit atrocities in Hogwarts give me
whatever it is you found here and we can
let bygones be bygones
sir
they had the key to the vote
choose your next words wisely I I only
meant that
so I must insist I was to Grant access
only the one with the key and you didn't
careful
[Music]
I have no patience patience that's how I
want to be okay I want to be that Savage
I'm not giving you anything
hmm well
perhaps your young friend here will be
more
yo he's strong
that little that little Goblin got some
it's got some kick to him
[Music]
foreign
that's rough man
isn't that like
structures isn't that important
are you all right
find sir
I've never seen so powerful a goblin he
seemed
holy unaffected by my magic yeah that's
my future powers
where are we I'ma learn what that Goblin
learned and I'm gonna use it to cause
havoc on the eight Realms five or six
how many Realms is in God of War and uh
puff to both
wanted someone with your ability
to end up here
come
we have a sorting ceremony to get to
Hogwarts
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
what's up Bellaire
don't want to put your name
ceremony
I'm no expert but that seems more
I need to study this locket as soon as I
can but first I must contact the
ministry they need to know what happened
to George and be warned of ramrock
for the moment I ask that you keep all
that's happened this evening between you
and me of course sir
thank you I like my green hair man ready
for the Sorting ceremony what's up
riddle ready
yeah
[Music]
oh yeah there's beef between them
Phineas Knight jealous black
prepare yourself to meet
the Headmaster
fig nice of you to join us
the Sorting sediment is over there were
complications complications it seems the
Goblin from us
goblins like no time for rumors so far
so good
so far so good
thumbs up so far we might still be able
to get you sorted this evening
touch
[Music]
foreign
we've won more to be sorted
welcome you're just into okay here we go
chat here we go
the moment of truth
what
house am I gonna belong to
we got some questions here we got some
answers we don't really got neither of
that but we got to have an answer I ah
yes a bit older than the others aren't
you
you come here with preferences and
preconceptions
certain expectations
what should we put should we put we
can't wait to start classes or I can't
wait to to explore
you know I feel like I feel like the
Sorting had these tests to me right now
we don't want to fail
I'm leaning a little bit towards we want
to start classes because the classes
lead to more power more power leads to
me to becoming a menace quicker
so what are we doing what are we doing
watch it be a Hufflepuff
I don't know man I don't know
[Music]
explore I don't trust you Belle you're
gonna put end up having me on the wrong
class all right all right all right all
right all right hold up hold up hold up
hold up
[Music]
is that we're gonna do it you know this
this
soundtrack reminds me of a lot of um
of
it reminds me a lot of
fable
if you guys want to be honest here
[Music]
all right all right chat this is what
we're gonna do I'm gonna give you guys
30 seconds
which one are we doing 30 seconds you
have to pick on that pole
you got 30 seconds
[Music]
oh we got we got 33 67 oh 44 to 56 oh 50
to 50. keep going let's go we gotta
break that we gotta break it man
we got to break the there we go 54 54 oh
it's this time again
53-47
[Music]
oh you're gonna let the 56 to 44 at the
explore guys are losing they losing
oh 53-47
50 50.
give me 10 seconds 10.
nine
[Music]
eight
seven
six
five
four
three
[Music]
two
one
[Music]
and it is explore
I'm looking forward to exploring
Hogwarts and the world beyond the castle
and grounds
[Music]
indeed I'm assuming I'm about to ask
another question
experience
but your professors have a great deal to
teach you as well
I wonder
I detect something I'm gonna let you
guys pick
the class that I picked
what is it
I did something you certain
what does
he
detects
daring
curiosity
that would probably make more sense than
anything
loyalty
or ambition
let's do this
[Music]
what are we picking guys what are we
picking I would say loyalty okay there
you guys go ambition man you guys are
you guys are messing with me man you're
messing with me it's looking like
ambition gonna win by a long shot right
now curiosity you know I'm a little
curious I'm a little curious I can
understand that
ambition is just it's it's it's hitting
man it's hitting it's hitting hard
65 man 65 percent
[Music]
all right ambition go win it's gonna win
there ain't nothing we can do it's gonna
win
is its ambition
I may seem single-minded but it is
important to go after what you want from
life
[Music]
interesting you've recently learned that
you possess a rare ability
I detect a growing sense of ambition an
eagerness for power
you guys are getting me to be Slytherin
so they want me to go with slither
[Music]
the the Sorting Hat will take your
choice into account when sorting you
into your house Slither knows for
cutting ambition and hunger for power
see look look you guys you guys played
me
you guys knew what I didn't want to do
and now the Sorting Hat who am I to go
against the Sorting Hat who am I to tell
the sword he had no
who am I to do that
really though let's let's get technical
though let's get technical the Sorting
Hat
is sorting my chat into Slither not me
is sorting my chat into Slytherin
because I just said classes
and I'd have said loyalty
but that's just me
but you guys
are low-key
manipulating me into choosing what you
guys want to do
and I'm with it
I'm with it we're doing this Slytherin
look at that evil grin they know what's
about to happen they know I'm about to
be a menace to society
[Applause]
that's right everybody clap everybody
clap this is the future
[Music]
due to the unfortunate injury on the
pitch in last Spring's final this year's
quidditch season has been canceled
I love how they don't want it they
didn't have time to put quidditch in the
game it seems like because I I haven't
heard about it being in the game so
they're like we're just gonna cancel the
season
you are here to focus on your academic
Futures I like how they did that because
what that is showing is putting lore
behind something that's not in the game
shouldn't be in the game probably it's
probably going to be in the game in the
future they'll probably do a free update
or something but the fact that they put
some form of lore to the reason why it's
not in the game I'm for that
quite an entrance it's lovely to meet
you I'm Professor Weasley would you be
so kind as to show our new students I
shall see to it sir we Slither we
slithering it up
nice to meet you as well professor
right this way
I'm gonna put that up as a YouTube video
the chat
bullied me
into becoming Slytherin for a student to
begin as a 50th
50th one I'm
sure I can be quite resourceful look at
the scars man I look villainous
I just I just I just lack the power but
I already look villainous
look like I can already walk into a room
and scare people
I just need the power to do it well
inspiration
I don't hear snakes though aren't you
supposed to hear snakes to get in
Slytherin
and get some sleep you have a big day
ahead of you tomorrow I shall be back in
the morning to collect you for your
first class
thank you Professor Weasley you're
welcome
I hope you enjoy your first night at
Hogwarts
sleep well
man this game looks phenomenal I have to
it looks phenomenal I'm gonna get um
something in my deck that uh
is clapping because I don't like doing
this this is it's like everyone's gone
about to head to the common room
well we going to the common room
see right now you know we we a little
Padawan we can't go crazy on people
but one day one day introductions are in
order
no we don't introduce it villains Don't
Make Friends
uh you might want to think about it
wait one day I'll be able to hit you
guys
we might want to think that again
I think I heard one
without mermaids find us that
interesting
ah based on all the chatter When you
entered the common room I'm guessing
you're the new fifth year I'm ominous
ominous gond nice to meet you ominous
Well you certainly had a memorable
arrival
okay
well if I'm going to make my Mark here I
had to start right away gotta be cocky
man you're definitely in the right house
do let me know if I can be a future
villain has to be cocky to some degree
though I doubt you'll need it
thank you ominous very nice to meet you
pleasure was all mine don't be a
stranger
not being a stranger my dude if you do
that you'll lose trust me
watch this
so far so good
checkmate
told you
just Spartan so far so good really
enjoying the game I'm a Slytherin
because the chat tricked me
you are you're the new Slytherin the one
who barged in with professors I said the
whole time I didn't want to be a
Slytherin but they on your first day
they they didn't listen from the first
years
I'm Imelda by the way shame I wasn't
with you and fig I could have lured that
Dragon away my skills in a brim are
legendary
perhaps Professor Fig's friend would
have survived if we'd had your help
precisely perhaps one of those days I'll
show you a thing or two about flying I
can teach you more than Kagawa ever
could speak who's Kagawa I'd like to get
in some time on my broom before classes
next meeting you
Man the game looks good guys like it
really do
I do that
can I help you
oh
you're the new fifth year how does
everyone know who I am
welcome to Slytherin thank you not
everyone has a Ministry escort to school
he was a friend of Professor figs who
merely joined us for the ride still
impressive Dreadful way to go poor
fellow
glad you and figure all right
fake and I were lucky to escape with our
lives indeed how does everyone know
everyone's business it's all still
everyone knows everyone's business in
this game you just get yourself settled
you can talk more later
nice to meet you it was nice meeting you
Sebastian Sebastian you can get back to
your book never changed my name it would
be you know Sebastian
it just sounds so elegant
with you
good morning if I trust you're ready for
your friends yeah they're mad nosy
they're mad that's for sure
I don't believe I'm here well you are
here make the most of it you only have
one first day at Hogwarts now in light
of your unique situation joining us as a
fifth year you'll need to catch up with
your classmates and not fall behind
especially as you'll be expected to
complete your owls at the end of the
year owls
owls yes your ordinary Wizarding level
exams they will determine what type of
career you can have when you leave here
after much discussion with the
Headmaster and the department of magical
education at the ministry we've devised
something extraordinary to ensure
yourself it's extraordinary
what is this
about book
did all the Spells leave what is it
track of what you are learning so that
you master all that's expected of a
fifth year
you would be wise to take full advantage
of this exceptionally valuable resource
foreign
[Music]
we'll answer any questions you may have
walk with me and we shall put it to the
test
we're gonna put it to the test this way
all right let's put it to the test let's
see what she means
what is this certainly would have
appreciated something like the field
guide when I was a student
okay but you didn't get it
you're lucky I can't oh
see I did say I wouldn't mess with the
teachers but if I could oh
bet you if I hit her quick
she wouldn't even know what hit her
to press your magic and educate yourself
about most likely I would throw a spell
at her it would do no damage as she
turned around and demolished me
on that rebellion and see what details
the field guide can provide
[Music]
all right I like this
foreign
I got my spell book in my hands
keep your eyes open for more
opportunities like that inside and
outside of the castle
[Music]
yeah I feel you I could easily play this
on a harder difficulty but I don't know
man
to me I just
it doesn't bother me to play on harder
difficulties
ah good timing
perfect opportunity to show you how to
use blue flames to get around a bit
quicker your field guys
like a travel system yeah fast travel
system
oh I like the way it looks
foreign
here okay let's talk a little bit about
difficulty
I don't like difficulty because I feel
like a lot of it's artificial they're
not really making the designing the game
to be difficult they're designing the
game to be more annoying to be more
difficult most the time when they put
something on there they're like we're
gonna give it more Health we're going to
make you take more damage they don't
make the AI smarter they don't do
anything like that for the most part
most games now if they started doing
more stuff like that where I generally
felt like it was testing me in a way
that didn't mean giving the enemies more
health and making me take more damage
I'd be more up for it but they don't
really do that
um I've seen all the movies uh Jay but I
do think that this game will hit you
more if you see the movies
but it doesn't look like you need to see
the movies
uh it just seems like it will hit you
more if you see the movies if that makes
sense
[Music]
the grand staircase
that's probably where we're at
what's
what is the PS5 version I think they
have exclusive stuff I don't know they
have some form of exclusive stuff
select the library
and here we are quite the Time Saver
these stairs lead directly to Central
Hall
appreciate it Jay
anywhere in the castle
oh there's something happening here it's
the heart of the hive our King's cross
station so to speak
that should be all for now you'll be
expected to attend both charms and
defense against the dark arts class yeah
we need to fix it against the dark
guards
you get to hogsmeade as
um
I don't know thank you Professor Weasley
we can look it up later
you need to stop watching series because
nah man like ACG gonna get you on the
right track you know what's worse buying
a game that's good because ACG
recommended to you or buying a game
that's bad because you didn't watch
agg's reviews he did Professor go watch
my reviews too as to the events
preceding your arrival I didn't get the
game like a review copy or anything like
that so
dragon attack
my suspicion is that there's more to the
story than a search for belongings and
an extended trip up to the castle
we did take a bit of a detour on the way
here ended up exploring some ruins and I
shouldn't say more exploring
well
reasons for keeping the details to
himself for now
speak of the devil Professor Fick
professors
oh yes
seem to have provided our new fifth year
with a solid foundation in the basics of
spell casting ah I'm afraid I can't take
all the credit there Professor they have
a rare aptitude for magic it seems hmm
well I'm just glad you both arrived in
one piece perfectly good boats and
carriages to Hogwarts and you chose to
fly in the path of a dragon I wouldn't
say I chose the dragon's path Professor
rather unfortunately yeah I wanted to
spend the day with the girl enough Chit
Chat uh you guys got me now man you
could have me back then but that one and
spent the day with the girl and I could
be single right now
gotta balance stuff man gotta balance
life
good luck today because most likely I
ain't gonna go see her for two days so I
needed some give and take or some give
and take invaluable to me as I'll be
using it to keep up to date on your
progress yes yes professor come and find
me in my classroom after you've attended
both classes today and I'll explain more
about those assignments I mentioned and
we'll see if we can't get you to
hogsmead for those supplies
thank you
so it makes it any easier the noise from
there is
good to see you professor and you I was
hoping that path would cross today
before you immersed yourself in studies
did I hear you and Professor Weasley
talking about
exploring ruins
[Music]
yes sir but I didn't tell her anything
else about her travel set I will say I
think she suspects we're not being
entirely forthcoming yes oh my God
people are cutting they're cutting me uh
it was the the part where I was talking
about the dragon eating the dude we
don't know where this path we've
embarked upon will lead
it may require a bit more flexibility
with your time than she would approve of
and she may feel obliged to share
details with the Headmaster that would
be better left between us understood
Professor good now as capable as you are
I believe the ability you possess
obliges you to be well trained happily
you have the benefit of an exceptionally
skilled team of witches and wizards to
guide you yeah teach me how to do it man
and so that I may avoid Another Not So
subtle proof from Professor Weasley why
don't I show you the clever enchantment
we included in the field guidesmap
unfold it and have a look
foreign
I don't think this is what he wanted me
to do
charms star cards
is Enchanted oh okay okay that is what
they wanted to be helpful thank you now
sounds like you've quite a day ahead
what with classes and a trip to hogsmeat
for supplies including your own wand
you'll enjoy Mr Ollivander he's an
exceptional Craftsman and a good friend
I shall reach out when I have more
information about our mysterious locket
for now focus on your classes and pay
attention more than your owls May hinge
on them I think if I was a wizard it
would be the most attention I would ever
pay
ever imagine like like the difference of
school if you could become powerful I
would there would be no existence of me
not paying attention in a school
teaching me how to do magic
it's crazy I'm playing on performance a
Abe performance mode
can
Rebellion
what is this
okay so it's spells that I haven't
unlocked
foreign
we're not doing charms yet
we're going straight for the dark arts
we're going to learn the dark arts chat
I need the dark arts to become a villain
[Music]
you've got
Professor hack it perhaps you'd be good
enough to blast each other to pieces on
your own time I get new students every
year but I only have one hebridium black
skull
it was a token from the great poker raid
of 1878 no doubt you've heard of it yeah
she being extra yeah you guys could kill
each other just don't don't mess up my
skull took out the largest poachering in
eastern Wales and lived to boast about
it
so I told you the teacher's gonna be a
problem
if I tried to pop off to this chick she
gonna Mark me which matches very little
today we will review a spell um
Mr uh lion blood I don't know right now
obviously it's the beginning of a game
a lot of games at the beginning is kind
of slow because they're explaining a lot
of scenarios to you
weak offend yourself most approach no
one thing I've learned as an unspeakable
is the value of Simplicity especially in
the heat of battle now let's practice
what we've just learned starting with
something small
foreign
oh
I missed the first one but it's okay we
still got it
Leviosa
levioso
[Music]
it's a floating technique
no let's try something a little larger
[Music]
foreign
let us begin with the basic cost
see how the dummy deflected your cast
yeah this is a pretty Birth cast
clevioso first then the basic cost
remember a surprised opponent
[Music]
gotta be extra good but the best way to
practice is by dueling
yeah with you there we go
time for a proper Hogwarts welcome now
now I want a fair tool using only
levioso basic cost and protego watch me
get my behind destroyed by this person
[Music]
come on come on come on come on
I worried about you what you doing kid
what you doing
yeah get off the platform
that's how we do things here
not bad not bad I destroyed you you
didn't even hit me Sebastian stop
trapping
Sebastian over here he he he he hurt he
got to go and lick his name put you on
the spot and you Rose to the challenge
Slytherin thank you Professor Hackett
glad to have the opportunity to practice
if what I've seen today is any
indication we we can expect great things
from you I demand Excellence from my
students they are I like that that was
really fun I wish they would have let me
challenge I wish I could have just
marked the whole classroom classroom all
of them but battling dark Wizards or as
ever more likely goblins
understood Professor so I'd advise you
to keep practicing whenever you can
perhaps Mr sallow will have some ideas
for you
again well done today I shall reach out
soon with additional assignments
[Music]
all right that's enough spectacle for
one day class is dismissed
nah teacher get on here let's I want
always thought Leviosa was for First
Years
come on man yeah let's let's play again
nice work rematch I enjoyed that well
that duel was quite something everyone
will be talking about it no it wasn't
you got destroyed fam practice felt more
like I was Julie an expert didn't expect
a new student to be so Deft with a wand
then again perhaps this wasn't your
first duel
[Music]
I had my share of one combat it was
never
uh it was never yeah it was smashed it
in man you smear it in but I know better
magic requires intention and talent you
know
you might be a perfect fit for a certain
exclusive unsanctioned dueling
organization
sounds good we doing now that's how
we're going to become a village these
people are going to train us and we're
going to place the better people if you
want to fight the better students and
it's going to lead to fighting the
teachers and then we're going to take
over Hogwarts and then we're gonna take
over the world or sneak you into the
restricted section of the library you
just have to be clever enough not to get
caught thank you Sebastian I'll keep
that in mind good
pleasure chatting with you I'm sure I'll
see you soon perhaps somewhere
unsanctioned we'll see if your
performance today was sheer luck or
actual skill look for Luke and Brad will
be near the clock tower entrance
if you're interested
it's time
yeah
you're my young friend
achievement attend your first class
it pops up on my computer I see it
before you guys see it
we're gonna go get charms
we need all the information in the world
if we want to become the the best
villain
professor
when we have all the information and we
have all the best stuff we could become
the best villain
behind that's the goal today
is to become the villain
no one we can't be friends I am
we got to be a villain
have you met Professor running yet
that's whatever you give you get a
cheaper version doc I go for a PC if you
prefer achievements I go for Xbox this
would be a crucial
in your education on the art of child
work but I am confident you guys like my
uh with a passion and rigor requisite of
such It's a Mario right now every Mario
screensaver your textbooks to page five
I'm really excited about the Mario
before we move in
anyone here tell me the difference
between the incantations of the color
change and growth charms
anyone anyone
I am afraid it is too late to study now
yo that dude just like skank my the
seven months must have really taken a
toll on you all by the looks of it you
all spent your holidays practicing
obliviate on one another
uh
do you even remember how to perform a
basic summoning genre
well
it seems that we are in dire need of
review
everyone getting into players they do a
really good job of all these characters
I have to really give my hat off to them
textbooks to use as they blunt objects
you saw you so believe they are
harming them out of one another's hands
only one book will be needed but
partnership Miss Dale thank you get into
place now
foreign
[Music]
got another one man another ability I
killed
telekinesis I guess
you want to switch sweet learner
I see a lot of potential but remember
potential is nothing without practice
keep added you might just rival Miss on
eye here
oh very good everyone that's enough of
that well as you all seem to have the
basics down and it is an exceptionally
lovely day I was thinking that we might
have ourselves a little Excursion
outside for a spot of fresh air
after me
let's go
we're gonna win this
it's a wrap
hi
I've always found that fun goes hand in
hand with Mastery as I'm sure the
Quidditch players amongst us would agree
so what better than a bit of sport to
put our prowess with the summon each
test right what are we gonna do
yeah this teachers are just too powerful
yeah
man
so why don't we have our newest student
start us off
what are we about to do
very simply cast Akio on one of this
video to relinquish your child that's it
now I think very good
this should be simple
now there's going to be someone on the
other side fighting with me
sort out some friendly companies told
you miss onai would you care we're gonna
have some like tug of war stuff I wonder
if I can mark them
[Music]
you'll be the Justice before and miss
unai you are playing red clear
yes sir
foreign
oh okay hold up
[Music]
oh I'm about to get stomped I'm about to
get stalled
she gonna get perfect scores
I need a 50.
[Music]
come on come on yes
excellent
no no roll off roll off
that's annoying
there's no way I can win
here
I lost
she beat me
that's not the act of a villain
I should have won that
I'm ashamed of myself man
oh can you knock theirs off let us make
this a bit more interesting shall we
are they gonna be on each side this time
[Music]
oh I think we are well past interesting
at this point
I'll say
the enough chatter Focus now you will
need it
this round settles it all
what's this
oh you can okay
I got you I see you
I see you
[Music]
foreign
I gave her a 50.
all right all right all right we gotta
do this better
[Music]
I plan on knocking one of them off
foreign
okay
I see you
Stay Focus
yo can I start that over again
come on let me fight let me do that
again
oh my God it was
I had a plan
pretty good both of you no well done I
failed
I fell let me do it again
ah
I knocked one of mine off
did I knock mine off
gathered your things who did I knock off
mine are theirs
well done back there you took the loss
in striped didn't want to go too easy on
you took me weeks to become proficient
with Accu took weeks for me to get
anything right I could have SWAT oh yeah
I promise
oh my God
I feel like I could have done that
better
[Music]
that's good to hear it's a lot to take
in all at once
[Music]
they've teach divination here before I
knew it we had left Uganda and we're
halfway around the world at a new school
in a new country
wow it's been nice talking and competing
with you
better not keep him waiting until I
thought we had it guys
of course you can aloki failed us I
failed us you're so inclined
a word
you know it won't work you wanted to
speak with me Professor I did I trust
your first chance lesson lived up to
expectation well an outdoor competition
wasn't exactly the lesson I was
expecting sir what charm is there in the
expected miss one I is a talented witch
take it in stride one often gains the
most from the battles one has lost of
course professor it was a challenging
Match Miss onai is always a fierce
competitor though I sense that she is a
bit distracted of late
now Professor Weasley has asked that
your professors give you instruction
outside of the ordinary curriculum
expect to hear from me soon regarding a
special assignment that I am preparing
for you
that's cool
I'm gonna go crazy on this game I think
I am going to end it for the stream guys
um
I plan on playing more of this tomorrow
I'm gonna put my in the chat
you know if you guys want to see me go
crazy
because I'm going to you have no idea
when I start getting that power
I'm Gonna Be a Menace I probably won't
strain this a lot of tomorrow so go over
there click on that I'm gonna send you
guys to uh my friend J main over there
you know go over there and tell him
addict sent you set you guys you know
put in the chat even if you only over
there for a couple minutes hit the like
button tell them addict sent you you
know he puts in a lot of work and I
appreciate you guys coming through
definitely go there follow
that follow the addict uh that and then
we'll we'll get it everything man I
really appreciate everyone for coming
through this is a fun game and I'm
definitely going to be streaming this
tomorrow